[Musique]
et bienvenue à tous et bienvenue pour
cette quinzième finale au cours de
calcul rapide organisée conjointement
par le cdas et la peine de 8 de la rue
nous allons aujourd'hui retrouvé des
tous meilleurs au départ est cité
environ 14 me à concourir pour chanter
vous que ce soit c'est marcel d'oxygène
il fallait avoir trois manches et
chacune des manches il aura six
questions d'éducation plus porter trois
calculs mentaux roues pour l'égalité 0
10 secondes de réflexion
deux problèmes pour lesquels les aime ou
on va secondes de réflexion est
également une activité vitale pour
légaliser ou trente secondes de
réflexion
tout ceci sera contrôlée par le l'autre
jury composé de deux personnes un vieux
michel
inspecteur d'académie inspecteur
pédagogique de musique et jeux
déconseillés
j le commis de grès dans la constitution
de saint pierre
nous allons maintenant on a commencé
avec la première manche chez les
servants et donc jamais été mon maillot
l'école kerri hannan de salazie et
jeanne d'arc ja de l'école d'application
de bellepierre à saint-denis
on va commencer donc la première partie
un calcul mental premiers calculs 72,7
plus 23,3 72,7 96
[Musique]
combien y at-il de mm dans 4,51 m
combien y at-il de mm dans 4,51 m quatre
cas de 1510 troisième calcul donne le
corps de 1204
[Musique]
donc on passe à la deuxième partie les
problèmes
premier problème lui dodik a réussi à
économiser 60 3 euros
il décide de s'acheter un livre qui
coûte 29 euros nous combien lui
reste-t-il
après son agent c'était une autre
réponse travaux deuxième problème avec 3
kg de café on a pu préparer 600 tasse de
café
quelle est la quantité nécessaire en
grammes pour préparer une tasse avec 3
kg de café on a pu préparer 600 tasse de
café
quelle est la quantité nécessaire en
grammes pour préparer une tasse
à dents et des lunes heureusement
personne avant de trouver la route
donc la réponse était 5 g sur la v3 kg
de café qui fait 3000 grammes
on avait six sont un peu de café et 3000
/ 6 ans péter galassi alors nous pouvons
vraiment passé à d'activité montagne on
peut s'afficher devant l'ordinateur
je rappelle que vous avez pas de
problème si pendant regarde c'est parti
10h10 heure c'est la même réponse
[Musique]
félicitations à tous pour votre
participation
alors je vais le concept deuxième manche
j'ai laissé mon lecteur c'est moi et ma
famille non je m'appelle vecteur cm1 de
l'école dernière voilà donc on va
commencer la première partie calcul
mental premiers calculs 337 +54 plus 13
337 404 c'est une bonne mousse sous
marin mois deuxième calcul donne le
double de 451,5 donne le double de 451
2005 3e calcul 28,7
- lui il ya eu 8
[Musique]
c'était donc on va passer maintenant la
deuxième partie problème premier
problème
un bateau transporte des touristes il
commence par embarquer 151 passagers
un premier arrêt quarante-sept passagers
descendent tandis que 68 monde
combien y at il alors de passagers sans
c'est la bonne russe
deuxième problème une grande résidence
est composée de 12 immeubles
chacun d'eux qu'on dise étoles et chaque
étage comporte cinq appartements combien
yat-il d'appartements dans la résidence
une grande résidence est composée de
l'est aux immeubles
chacun d'eux compte dix étages et chaque
étage
6a parfait qui va travailler sur l'écran
j'aurai trente secondes de réflexion ses
bases
tu as tort centimètres seulement nous
dans les réunions je n'étais pas très
loin on fait des réponses ans étaient
quinze 15 cm elle fait bien s'organiser
pour compter sur le sur les dessins on
va faire le moins avec le jury je suis
parti de loin électorale qu'elle fit
manche et les braves ont livré la fois
c'est chez jc non ok allons donc on va
commencer la première partie calcul
mental le premier calcul 6030 / 6 2e
calcul entre parenthèses 64,5 +30 5,5 x
13 3e calcule combien y at-il de
centilitres dans 3 litres 5
[Musique]
c'est du bonheur
c'était parce que ces trois légumes
saint cricq produite route
alors on passe donc à la deuxième partie
problème premier problème
stéphanie vient de lire une bande
dessinée beau temps 11 euros elle
remarque que chacune des 48 parle
comporte neuf dessins combien y at-il de
dessin en tout dans cette bande dessinée
stéphanie vient de lire une bande
dessinée coûtant 11 euros elle remarque
que chacune des 48 pages comporte neuf
dessins combien y at-il de dessin en
tout dans cette bande dessinée 83
nouveaux
[Applaudissements]
quatre centres mieux c'est la marée
noire
deuxième problème au moment de nuit une
couleuvre
mais j'irai 55 cm et sa peau s'est
séparé en trois morceaux
gilles a trouvé un morceau de 25 cm et
un autre de 14 cm 3 mm combien me jure
le troisième morceau alors nous avons
passé le nom 50
dans les véhicules et avait fait 55 3
avaient décidé de regrouper par craquer
le ze5 france 55 3 on va faire le point
trois et quatre points juste chez les
cm2 maintenant que j'accueille mme
arthur
bonjour je suis à l'école saint charles
[Musique]
saint pierre bonne chance aux deux
premiers calculs donne le quadruple de
707 donne le quadruple de 707 2008 anges
c'est la maman ce deuxième calcul 12h45
- 1h55 troisième calcul 38,7
+99 +106 de ces deux ans et demi ce
n'est pas la bande à 38,7 +99 +106 dont
143 7 c'est la bonne la deuxième partie
problème donc pour prendre des notes
premier problème la maîtresse de servir
un verre de jus d'ananas à chacun des
vingt-sept élèves de sa place avec une
bouteille
elle te remplir hui vers combien
doit-elle apporter de bouteilles cassées
[Musique]
deuxième problème
martin achète un fauteuil valant 399
euros un canapé volant 699 euros et
bibliothèques valant autant que le
fauteuil et le canapé réunis combien
elle dépensé en tout
quand ils achètent la fauteuil n'est pas
la bonne réponse 2196 précise unités
voilà merci c'est la bonne réponse alors
nous allons passer maintenant à la
visite et mentale l'appareil se rend il
reprendre ce groupe c barre des 1500
milles 55
ce n'est pas la permanence au plus alors
qu'est ce qu'il fallait faire ce qui par
sa tâche est donc il fallait calculer
375 5 x 5
on utilise un simple plus simple x 10 et
de division suite pardonne la bonne
réponse était 1875
on va faire le point avec le jury
- jc ou arthur l'utilisé pas 3-0 alors
nous avons commencé donc cette deuxième
manche je les sais que je suis mais
thébaux 10 g je suis allée comme la nuit
à san jose le premier calcul 21,00 3 x
10 21,00 3 x 10
le temps écoulé un ami mais bon c'est
une 206 dire que les mouvements deuxième
calcul 57 / entre parenthèses 1,7 plus
1,3 57 / entre parenthèses 1,7 plus 1,3
soit troisième calcul 388 -199 388 -199
[Musique]
une armoire
premier problème de retour de vacances
pour le décide de ranger les 210 photos
qu'il a prises dans un album chaque
poche de son album peut compter nié en
cette photo combien de pages et de son
allemand pour moi qui le rend bien
deuxième problème
laura achète une voiture
lvs 14 1599 euros à la commande
puis 24 mensualités de 100 euros par
combien lui revient cette voiture saison
2009 104 euros ses abonnements vous
emmener ses manches par l'activité
mentale soit apparaître sur l'écran et
par asus
15 qui ce novateur et tous
30-30 qu il a quand même ans kg on va
faire le point avec eux je laisse ça de
la nouvelle édition
quatre points c'est pour faire la
troisième manche alors calcul mental
premiers calculs 1980 16,14 plus 3,86
[Musique]
deuxième calcul entre parenthèses 25,7
- 6 x 100 il ya socialiste c'est la
bonne réponse tumorale troisième calcul
832 / 8
[Musique]
premier problème
myriam a déjà lu le tiers d'un livre de
183 pages combien de pages lui
reste-t-il à dire sans lendemain deux
problèmes
pierre à un salaire mensuel de 1500
euros
combien gheit il en une année pierre un
salaire mensuel de 1500 euros
combien gates il en une année zinio
c'est maintenant procéder à la civis et
luton mme alvarez
c'est bon
18,5 m c'est moins que je ris je viens
les sucettes troisième manche arthur
quatre fois le team au t2 - arthur et
les chansons puisque nos félicitations
[Applaudissements]
eh bien nous allons moins de mots assez
niveau 6e avec la première manche jesse
l je m'appelle qualifier et je viens du
collège joseph turcot je m'appelle à
oignies kg maison blanche
[Musique]
alors première partie calcul mental
premiers calculs pas combien faut-il
multiplier 45 pour obtenir 4545
[Musique]
deuxième calcule combien font 50 poisson
296,2 ce n'est pas la bonne réponse
combien font cinq ans poissant 296,2
le temps écoulé donc là on cherche et
50% de 187 en vue de notre monde on
cherchait la moitié de 196 m de long 4
c'était 90 et 98,8 troisième calcul
entre parenthèses 88 plus 22 / entre
parenthèses 71 - 69 alors on passe à la
deuxième partie problème premier
problème 18 bus peuvent contenir 900
personnes combien de personnes peuvent
remonter dans le 27 bus
18 bus compte ni 1 900 personnes
combien de personnes peuvent monter dans
27 buts une fois 150 personnes
effectivement rarement c'est la bonne
réponse
deuxième problème chez le marchand de
légumes
naïma achète pour 5,25 euros de tomates
du salade à 85 centimes chacune et un
sac de pommes de terre à 3,75 euros
combien doit elle payer en tout tu vas 1
- alors maintenant nous passer le calacs
cité montalbanaise ses pinceaux
55 cm carré bonnat bonnes réponses sont
menées alors ce n'est pas non plus la
brousse il ya bien aux 121 petit carré
chaque carré à vos côtés 506 mètres
carrés à une mère de 25 5 325 donc il
fallait encore faire 121 x comme ça donc
le plus simple était de faire 121 x sont
puis 2 / gagner et donc on trouvait à 25
centimes à l'intérieur à ce stade on va
faire le moindre quel élu julie
reset rugueuse de débuter maintenant la
deuxième manche j'ai un bon jour j'en
suis leur canal man du collège jean hugo
de santé nicole premiers calculs 23,2 x
516 c'est la bonne route néanmoins
deuxièmes calcul 504 plus 799 504 plus
799 34
dans le défilé était pas seulement fait
1 5303 une petite bêtise troisième
calcul donne les deux tiers de 9012
donne lui donne les deux tiers du 9012
s'y sont mis
ce n'est pas coutume ce n'est pas trop
loin dans les deux cas je les aime et
que l'on se tient en effet le multiplie
par 2 ou 6008 ont pas selon lui un petit
problème si premier problème un polygone
de cette côte et un périmètre de 4 43 cm
cinq côtés ont une longueur égale à 4 cm
chacun les lieux et denis côté ont la
même longueur
quelle est cette longueur un polygone de
cette côte et à un périmètre de 43 cm
cinq côtés ont une longueur égale à 4 cm
chacun
[Musique]
les deux derniers côté ont la même
longueur quel sept longueurs osamu
simple précise unités nous nous sommes
sentis
[Musique]
deuxième problème
un lot de six briquettes de jus de
fruits côte 12,66 euros
combien coûte une seule brique être deux
a vu euros merci c'est la bonne réponse
alors nous allons passer à l'activité
mentale
attention on prend ce monde de réfléchir
à mon zinal
c'est parti
qu'est ce
j'attends la réponse est de 14,4 mahdi
en finition avait une maquette à
l'échelle 1 1 50e
il fallait retrouver l'âme il y aurait
elle donc il fallait prendre les 28,8 cm
x 50
le plus simple est de multiplier par
cent l'an x sans passer directement des
centimètres au m elle arrivait
directement à 28 m et en fait il fallut
/ donne 14,4 m ça pour faire le point
avec le jury que l'art 80
travaux de deux guitares et cette fois
c'est manche qu'elle est première partie
calcul mental premiers calculs 39,25 x 4
147 n'est pas la bonne route 157
[Musique]
deuxième calcul entre parenthèses 13,7
moins 6,6 / entre parenthèses 1,33 plus
8,67 entre parenthèses 13,7 moins 6,6 /
[Musique]
/ entre parenthèses 1,33 plus 8,67 0,17
ce n'est pas non plus la bonne mousse on
n'est pas très loin
c'était cd
effectivement on apprenait la nouvelle
se faisait 7,1 et a prévenu que ce parti
est de 0,73 troisième calcule combien
yat-il d'heure au mois de juin
combien y at il deux heures au mois de
juin cette somme en premier problème
lors de l'examen quatre cinquièmes des
mille candidats sont reçus
combien y at-il eu des candidats refusés
lors d'un examen quatre cinquièmes des
mille candidats sont reçus 800 sont
refusés ce n'est pas combien il y at il
deux candidats qu'ils étaient 150 élèves
ce n'est pas une bonne leçon 50
arrivant je pense que tu n'étais pas
loin tient pas bien entendu la question
de pension et me dit intéressé il ya 800
candidats reçus et donc uniquement lui
100 200 candidats refusés deuxième
problème un rectangle à une largeur de 5
cm et un périmètre de 26 cm quel est son
air avec dans mail largeur de 5 cm et un
périmètre de 26 cm quel est son air ce
n'est pas de 80 centimètres carrés ce
n'est pas nous donner peut-être trop
vite aussi alors on fait ces quarante
centimètres carrés
on a un père et le 26 cm on a nos deux
largeurs à 5 cm 5 x 2 10 26 - nice ça va
faire 16
mais après il faut diviser par deux on
va voir la largeur la longueur
cette barre de sa fille de 8 à léognan
2,8 largeur de 5
une fois 5 40 centimes alors nous reste
une activité mentale a duré 30 secondes
dans une version c'est parti
temps est écoulé malheureusement alors
la défense étaient 80 720
alors les gens regardez votre nom et le
par-5 donc il termine soit par 0,7 en
france mais aussi ici par quatre temps
qui peut pas s'ennuyer par simple qu'ils
arrivent déjà par zemmour ensuite il dit
par ne vous avez appris que la somme des
chiffres dans ces cas là est elle-même
visite par neuf et on a les huit plus un
ça fait 9 à 2,9 plus de ça fait 11 11 +
0 ça fait trop longue pour arriver aux
multiples et nocives en manque 7 donc la
réunion c
80 à 1720 on va faire le point avec le
jury sur marty toujours donc il ya
toujours l'égalité parfaite donc je vais
vous expliquer comment on va faire
on va passer aux questions subsidiaires
c'est le premier il ya une bonne réponse
à une question soutient il sera déclaré
champion nous donc ça va être
certainement dé la nationale 20 x 14 x
[Applaudissements]
5400 c'est la bns
[Musique]
félicitations bravo
le bardo à tout le monde avouez
la liste qui aujourd hui encore les
preuves de qualif pour un mantra peau
hâlée prochaine
[Musique]